[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend alles
was wir heute wissen müssen in den
nächsten 20 minuten natürlich gehört
sportlich dazu heute mit kristin otto
ich grüße sie genannt und hier sind
jetzt unsere themen
beben in der katholischen kirche einen
gutachten über sexuellen missbrauch
wirft auch papst benedikt schwere fehler
im umgang mit tätern und opfern vor
die ukraine krise entschärfen aber wie
aussenministerin baerbock und ihr us
kollege setzen weiter auf diplomatie
während moskau den westen provokation
vorwirft
wälster und weltenbummler hardy krüger
bekannt für filme wie einer kam durch
und hat ari ist mit 93 jahren gestorben
wir beginnen die sendung mit
schockwellen die im vatikan angekommen
sein dürften dass ein neues missbrauchs
gutachten mit benedikt dem sechzehnten
einen früheren papst belastet ist
beispiellos er soll in seiner zeit als
erzbischof in mindestens vier fällen
unzureichend gegen missbrauchs täter
vorgegangen sein seine aussage er habe
nichts gewusst bezweifeln die gutachter
stark auch dem amtierenden kardinal marx
werden fehler vorgeworfen über das
gutachten dass hunderte opfer auflistet
barbara lueg
im fokus der juristen heute stehen sie
kardinal wetter kardinal marx und der
emeritierte papst und frühere münchner
erzbischof joseph ratzinger der vorwurf
täter wurden geschützt die opfer nicht
in insgesamt vier fällen sind wir zu der
einschätzung gelangt dass dem damaligen
erzbischof kardinal ratzinger in fällen
sexuellen missbrauchs ein fehlverhalten
vorzuwerfen ist sein fall steht im
zentrum priester peter h werden
besonders viele missbrauchs taten
zugeschrieben zunächst als kaplan in
essen in den 70ern als es passiert ist
wilfried fesselmann elf jahre messdiener
heute spricht er über das grauen dann
hat er mir irgendwas alkoholisches zu
trinken gegeben und ja dann hat er sich
ausgezogen ich musste mich ausziehen ja
und am ende muss ich ihnen dann halt
oral befriedigen doch statt den
pädophilen priester zu entlassen wird er
nach münchen versetzt joseph ratzinger
ist dort zu der zeit erzbischof der
missbrauch des peter h geht weiter stets
hatte der emeritierte papst erklärt in
der entscheidenden sitzung und peter h
nicht dabei gewesen zu sein ich
formuliere zurückhaltend wir halten die
angabe des papstes benedikt er sei in
dieser sitzung nicht anwesend gewesen
als wenig glaubwürdig auch kardinal
wetter und dem amtierenden münchner
erzbischof marx werfen die gutachter
schweres fehlverhalten vor am nachmittag
tritt marx mit persönlichen worten vor
die kamera für mich haben die
begegnungen mit betroffenen sexuellen
missbrauchs eine wende bewirkt
sie haben meine wahrnehmung der kirche
verändert ausführlich will er sich nach
prüfung des gutachtens in einer woche
äußern
so einordnung des brisanten gutachtens
ist seit der kirchenexperte jürgen
erbacher jetzt bei uns im studio guten
abend haben der erbacher der frühere
papst soll gelogen missbrauchs täter
gedeckt weiter beschäftigt haben wie
sehen sie es in der tat steht die
glaubwürdigkeit von benedikt dem
sechzehnten auf dem spiel wir wussten
schon lange dass bei dem einen fall
aussage gegen aussage steht wir haben
gerade die aussage eines der anwälte
gehört die das gutachten erstellt haben
jetzt liegt nahe dass der papst bisher
da nicht die richtige antwort gegeben
hat die wahrheit gesagt hat der vatikan
und auch benedikt sekretär erzbischof
kennzahlen haben heute schon angekündigt
sie werden das gutachten jetzt genau
studieren die betroffenen erwarten jetzt
natürlich eine klare stellungnahme von
benedikt dem sechzehnten und auch dass
er verantwortung übernimmt der vorwürfe
gibt es auch gegen den aktuellen
münchner erzbischof marx
fehlverhalten in zwei missbrauchsfällen
er hat sich entschuldigt hat sich zeit
erbeten womit dieser zu rechnen jetzt
gut da wird in einer woche erste
konsequenzen vorstellen ich glaube nicht
dass er nochmal zu dem jetzigen
zeitpunkt seinen rücktritt anbieten wird
ich habe ihn heute zum einen erschüttert
erlebt angesichts dieser verbrechen die
dort an dem tag noch mal gekommen sind
und jetzt hier dargelegt sind auf der
anderen seite auch kämpferisch er hat
gesagt aufarbeitung geht nur mit reform
der kirche und das heißt er bekennt sich
klar dazu die systemischen ursachen die
missbrauch begünstigt und vertuschung
begünstigt haben anzupacken dagegen gibt
es widerstand von einigen
bischofskollegen aber auch aus rom marx
hat sich heute klar pro reformen
ausgesprochen als ein entscheidender weg
zur aufarbeitung von missbrauch und für
einen klaren blick auf die betroffenen
vielen dank für die einordnung jürgen
erbacher und so thematik gibt es bei uns
auch eine würdigung ein zdf spezial
gutachten zum missbrauch schwere
vorwürfe gegen die katholische kirche
direkt nach unserer sendung
zur situation jetzt in der ukraine da
bleibt es extrem angespannt an der
grenze während die russische marine
heute ein internationales militärmanöver
mit über 100 kriegsschiffen ankündigte
wurden wieder eindringliche warnung
richtung moskau geschickt genauer aus
berlin wo us-außenminister blinken heute
zu besuch bei annalena baerbock und olaf
scholz war ines trams berichtet
einigkeit soll das bild symbolisieren
die deutsche außenministerin mit ihren
kollegen aus washington paris und london
geschlossen sind sie so die botschaft an
russland und koordiniert würden sie
sanktionen verhängen im falle eines
übergriffs auf die ukraine wir fordern
russland dringend dazu auf schritte zur
deeskalation zu unternehmen jede weitere
aggressive haltung jede weitere
aggressivität würde gravierende
konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
egal welchen weg russland wählt es wird
die usa deutschland und seine partner
vereint vorfinden
erleichtert zeigt sich us-außenminister
blinken dass auch kanzler scholz die
umstrittene ostsee-pipeline nun als
sanktionen in betracht zieht noch fließt
kein gas durch nord stream zwei die
pipeline ist also ein druckmittel für
deutschland die usa und unsere partner
nicht für russland us präsident biden
hatte zuvor für verwirrung gesorgt er
rechne mit einer russischen eskalation
sagte er und deutete an dass angedrohten
sanktionen vom ausmass eines
potenziellen russischen angriffs
abhängen es ist eine sache wenn es sich
um ein geringfügiges eindringen
russlands in die ukraine handelt aber
wenn die russen tatsächlich das tun wozu
sie mit den truppen an der grenze in der
lage sind dann wird das für russland
eine katastrophe werden
hatte beiden damit etwa grünes licht
gegeben für einen geringfügigen
grenzübertritt russlands klarstellung
sollten irgendwelche russischen truppen
über die ukrainische grenze gehen wieder
aggressiv vorgehen dann wird es darauf
eine rasche ernsthafte und gemeinsame
antwort geben
sowie
ein treffen mit kanzler scholz bevor
blinken morgen in genf den russischen
außenminister spricht dann wird sich
zeigen ob die diplomatie eine chance hat
im ukraine konflikt
wir wollen noch mal den blick auf die
irritierenden aussagen von us-präsident
beiden wänden claudia bates in
washington wie muss man das einschätzen
herr präsident biden äußerungen senden
schockwellen durch die diplomatische
welt es geht ja um zwei punkte zum einen
relativierte er den umfang der reaktion
je nachdem wie russland vorgehen würde
und zum anderen sprach er auch von
unstimmigkeiten innerhalb der nato was
natürlich zur unzeit kommt die ukraine
zeigte sich geschockt die republikaner
hier in den usa sprechen von einem
fiasko und diplomaten fürchten seine
äußerungen schwächen die abschreckung
und würden es noch schwieriger machen
jetzt eine diplomatische lösung zu
finden
präsident biden ist nun dafür berüchtigt
für verbale schnitzer und hat heute
deswegen gleich klargestellt was er
gestern meinte ein übertreten der russe
in der ukrainischen grenze durch
russische einheiten sei eine invasion
eine koordinierte reaktion würde folgen
und putin würde einen hohen preis dafür
bezahlen danke nach washington claudia
welt
jetzt zu corona und der aktuellen
situation die zahl der neuinfektionen
ist wieder auf einen neuen höchstwert
gestiegen und das robert koch institut
registrierte
133 1536 neue fälle innerhalb eines
tages
52.000 119 mehr als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen 234 todesfälle hinzu die
sieben tage incidents liegt jetzt so
hoch wie nie bei 600
38,8 und worüber hier noch kontrovers
diskutiert wird kommt ab februar in
österreich die korona impfpflicht mit
großer mehrheit hat das parlament dem
vorhaben gerade eben zugestimmt demnach
drohen impfverweigerer an strafen
zwischen 600 und 3600 euro um die
impfquote zu steigern verspricht die
regierung auch ein belohnungs paket
jeder geimpfte kann an einer im flottere
teilnehmen bei der gutscheine im wert
von 500 euro verlost werden britta
hilpert jetzt mit den einzelheiten
in wien sorgt die impfpflicht für
gerangel vor dem parlament aber für eine
parteiübergreifende mehrheit darin gegen
die omikron infektionswelle jetzt hilft
sie wohl kaum doch trotzdem meint die
regierung
wir müssen uns darauf vorbereiten dass
wir nach der mikrowelle über die
nächsten monate geht verlieren werden in
österreich wien nicht gibt wird drei
phasen hat die impfpflicht ab anfang
februar gilt sie ab mitte märz wird
kontrolliert und wer ohne grund
ungeimpft ist muss strafe zahlen
zunächst 600 euro ab april wird gegen
jeden ohne eintrag im zentralen imf
register ein strafverfahren eingeleitet
höchststrafe 3600 euro diese phase soll
ausgesetzt werden falls bereits genügend
immunisiert sind eine ausstiegsklausel
für ein umstrittenes gesetz
selbstverständlich sind die geimpften in
der klaren mehrheit aber in absoluten
zahlen gerechnet sind die ungeimpften
und auch die deklarierten impfgegner
hunderttausende oder millionen in einem
kleinen land wie in österreich viel zu
viel als dass wir diese polarisierung
einfach in kauf nehmen können mit
ausnahme der rechtspopulistischen fpö
unterstützt aber auch die opposition das
gesetz österreich führt damit als erstes
land der eu die impfpflicht 1
so israel hat drei weitere u-boote in
deutschland bestellt der auftrag geht an
die kieler thyssenkrupp werft die boote
kosten rund drei milliarden euro einen
teil der kosten trägt die
bundesregierung das erste boot soll in
neun jahren ausgeliefert werden israel
besitzt aktuell 6 u boote aus
deutschland
sie wissen die bundesregierung will
tempo machen beim ausbau erneuerbarer
energien und setzt vor allem auf
windkraft
deutschlandweit gingen im vergangenen
jahr knapp 500 neue windräder in betrieb
im flächenmäßig größten bundesland in
bayern aber gerade mal acht ein grund
eine besonders strenge abstandsregelung
bayern muss mehr liefern findet
klimaschutzminister habeck der heute
nach münchen reiste alexander pohl
im oberbayerischen fuchstal zahlt sich
die energiewende für die anwohner aus
sie haben in diesen windpark investiert
die rendite zweistellig so könnten an
vielen orten in bayern neue windräder
entstehen wäre da nicht diese eine regel
nach zum teil heftigen widerstand gegen
den bau von windrädern wurde in bayern
2014 ein gesetz verabschiedet zehnmal
die höhe des windrads so groß muss die
entfernung zur nächsten wohnsiedlung
sein wenn sie die 10h regel behalten
dann bauen sie in oberbayern vielleicht
nur 100 windräder das war's dann in
bayern sollen jedes jahr zwischen 150
und 200 windräder gebaut werde um die
klimaziele zu erreichen für ihn die
oberste politische priorität
robert habeck heute auf besuch in bayern
zwar lobt der klimaschutzminister die
bilanz des freistaats bei der
photovoltaik oder der wasserkraft aber
wir brauchen eben auch einen
ökologischen patriotismus beim ausbau
von schwierigen techniken der windkraft
der bayerische ministerpräsident söder
zeigt sich kompromissbereit
ausnahmen von der zehnjährige könne es
wohl geben am eigentlichen gesetz aber
will söder festhalten wir glauben nicht
dass das der alleinige grund für die
schwäche des windes der windkraft denn
sie uns während baden württemberg und in
anderen bundesländern ja ein einen
riesen boom da gibt es nämlich kein 10h
der bürgermeister von fuchstal bleibt
dabei die 10h regel müsse weg sein
modell der bürgerbeteiligung an
windrädern schaffe akzeptanz die
bayerische staatsregierung hat nun bis
märz zeit zu erklären wie die windkraft
in bayern trotz zehn haarige wieder in
schwung kommen kann
fünf tage nach dem mega ausbruch eines
vulkans in einem tsunami vor tonga ist
immer noch unklar wie schwer die schäden
auf den inseln sind mittlerweile sind
aber hilfsgüter angekommen aus
australien und neuseeland an bord der
maschinen unter anderem trinkwasser
generatoren und kommunikationsausrüstung
möglich werden die flüge weil die
landebahn auf der hauptinsel
mittlerweile von asche befreit werden
konnte
jetzt nehmen wir abschied von einer
deutschen legende einem weltstar hardy
krüger ist im alter von 93 jahren
gestorben
als schauspieler schaffte er es bis nach
hollywood als offizier als großwildjäger
in hatari sunnyboy privat zog es den
weltenbummler immer in die ferne zuletzt
engagierte er sich gegen
rechtsextremismus geprägt durch seine
kindheit und jugend im
nationalsozialismus über den großen
hardy krüger sarah schuhen
es ist dieses lächeln dass hardy krüger
berühmt machte so lässig so unverschämt
gut aussehend berühmt wurde in den 60ern
mit seiner rolle im großwild film hatari
dem kontinent afrika fühlte er sich seit
dem tief verbunden in dem zusammenhang
habe ich gesagt mein herz ist genauso
schwarz für das von leuten die eine
schwarze haut haben seine kindheit
verlief völlig anders hardy krüger
stammt aus einem stramm
nationalsozialistischen eltern regime
treuer drill in der adolf hitler schule
statt menschenliebe doch der jugendliche
krüger durchschaut die grausamkeit des
nationalsozialismus an der front wieder
setzt er sich einen befehl der für ihn
und seine kameraden den sicheren tod
bedeutet hätte ich habe gesagt das mache
ich nicht und der kleine hat auch gesagt
ich mach dich nicht den erstmal
erschossen und dann wollte er mich
erschießen aber dazu ist nicht mehr
gekommen ich habe ihnen erschossen
krüger überlebt und ihm gelingt was für
einen deutschen in der nachkriegszeit
unmöglich erscheint der durchbruch im
internationalen filmgeschäft ja das habe
ich verstand seine vergangenheit lässt
ihn zeit seines lebens nicht los er
engagiert sich gegen rechtsextremismus
und reist noch im hohen alter immer
wieder durch die republik spricht von
schulklassen über seine erfahrungen im
dritten reich dann sage ich denen ich
bin gekommen um dafür zu sorgen dass
euch so etwas ähnliches nicht geschieht
seine rolle im film war oft die des
strahlenden sunnyboys im alter wurde er
vor allem ein couragierter mahner
vergessen für hardy krüger war das ein
unerträgliches wort
toller typ wir machen mit dem sport
weiter dfb pokal wieder überraschungen
absolut wenn die kleinen die großen
ärgern ein achtelfinale mit
seltenheitswert alle pokal gewinner der
vergangenen 29 jahre sind bereits raus
darunter auch borussia mönchengladbach 0
2 3 in hannover dazu die misere in der
bundesliga gladbach rutscht weiter in
die krise
ungemütlich ist das in mönchengladbach
aus den letzten acht spielen nur ein
sieg nach der desaströsen leistung in
hannover wächst der druck auf trainer
adi hütter
ist klar wenn man so ausscheidet wie wir
wird diskussionen gegeben
nichtsdestotrotz hätte mir hörte man
über diese fürchterliche niederlage die
einfach ihr sind
schmerzhaft die blutleere eigene
vorstellung aber auch die starke
konsequente leistung der 96er maximilian
bayer bereits nach drei minuten
sebastian karg mit einem handelfmeter
noch einmal der 19 jährige bayer treffen
beim sieg des imponierenden
zweitligisten rosentreter hütter braucht
jetzt am samstag gegen union berlin sehr
dringend ein erfolgserlebnis
tennisprofi philipp kohlschreiber ist
als vorletzter deutscher spieler bei den
australian open in melbourne
ausgeschieden
nach den ersten beiden klar verlorenen
sätzen gegen den spanier gut ein kurzes
aufbäumen mit einigen guten ballwechseln
mehr aber auch nicht kohlschreiber im
grünen trikot unterlag 160 zu 63 zu
sechs damit verbleibt alexander zverev
als einziger deutscher im einzel turnier
und keine top ten platzierungen für die
deutschen biathleten zum weltcup-auftakt
im italienischen antholz benedikt doll
wurde als bester über 20km zwölfter
benedikt doll unterliefen bei
wechselnden winden zu viele schießfehler
insgesamt vier und er bekam dafür viel
strafminuten läuferisch war die leistung
des 31 jährigen aber stark er belegte
nach der schnellsten schlussrunde am
ende platz zwölf überraschungssieger in
antholz der russe anton bubikopf der als
einziger viermal alle scheiben traf und
das prestigeträchtige einzel vor dem
norweger tarjei bö und seinem landsmann
khalili gewarnt barbie kopf sie der acht
jahre nach seinem bisher einzigen
weltcup erfolg war ebenso hätten wir
auch gern hinter ann christin schnee und
glätte gibt es in der nacht und was noch
gleich von erster intelli
us-außenminister blinken zur ukraine
krise später ab 21.55 im heute-journal
interview mit bettina schausten das 19
uhr heute die ihm sagt danke fürs
zuschauen schönen abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kaltluft war heute
vorherrschend über deutschland sie wird
allmählich abgedrängt aber sie sorgte
heute für kräftige schauer dass es diese
gepunktete bewölkung die von nordwesten
reingezogen ist das reinste aprilwetter
ausgelöst hat also regen schnee
graupelschauer unter zwischen
sonnenschein diese kompakten wolken die
legen sich nun an die alpen oder schneit
es dann in der nacht weiter die
schneeglatte sonst generell mit glätte
dann müssen sie rechnen denn es wird
eisig kalt die temperaturen gehen im
vogtland bis auf minus 7 grad zurück an
den alpen auf -6 frostfrei einzig im
nordwesten mit plus 2 grad sonst
verbreitet frostig kalt morgen dann im
tagesverlauf für einzelne schauer im
westen regen ist jetzt nun auch wieder
dabei schnee nach südosten hin sonst
viel sonne im osten deutschlands und das
bei höchsten temperaturen von minus drei
grad an den alpen hier also dauerfrost
und 8 grad im nordwesten deutschlands ja
viel schnee gibt es am samstag an den
alpen hier im südosten deutschlands
ansonsten ist es größtenteils trocken
bei null bis acht grad und die nächsten
tage werden allmählich trockener ein
schöner abend